Final note on sort. All the algorithms we discussed were what we call key sorts,
where we only sort a set of keys. Many interesting applications, however,
require that you sort not just a key, but a value associated with that key.
For instance, in unit two Dave described sorting a set of NBA players by height.
In this case, the key might be the height, and the value would be the player's name,
the player's team, the player's history and so on.
Dealing with values as well as keys is pretty straightforward.
First, if you have a value that's large in terms of bytes, it's usually smarter to make the value instead,
a pointer to the actual data, and then just sort the value and its pointer.
For instance, if you had a large NBA player data structure, don't sort the whole data structure as the value.
Instead, just use a pointer to the data structure as the value.
Second, our sort algorithms generally move around data keys,
whether that be a sorting network, or a radix sort, or a merge.
Instead of just moving the key, if you have to deal with a key value sort,
move the key and the value together as one unit.
Finally, since today's GPUs can often natively handle 64-bit data,
it might make sense to use a 64-bit data type to store both a 32-bit key and a 32-bit value
and just change any comparison functions you have to input 64-bit values instead.